hey David how do we move the Republican
Party to the left it's a good question
and there are basically two answers
number one is we move the Republican
Party to the left by moving the
Democratic Party they love the second
answer is we move the Republican Party
to the left by working at the local
level like Republicans are so good at
doing to get left wingers elected to
school boards and City Council's and PTA
you know whatever at the local level
because this is how Republicans have
successfully won thousands of seats if
you consider down to the local level
tens of thousands of seats even excuse
me over the last several years several
decades actually number one if we can
move the Overton Window to the left of
national political discussions the
Republican Party is going to have to
come left at least on some issues a lot
of them have on the issue of gay
marriage for example it feels like so
long ago but it wasn't that long ago
that the Supreme Court decision in June
of 2015 said you can't ban same-sex
marriage at the state level and not all
there's still a lot of money raised in
evangelical circles around being
anti-gay but a lot of Republicans have
just sort of forgotten about it and they
are now at least centrists on the issue
of gay marriage it's just one example as
we continue to move the conversation to
the left on health care the catalyst for
which was Bernie Sanders back in 2016
inserting this issue in a serious way
into the public discussion overall you
are pulling Republicans to the left as
well now they still want free market
blah blah blah all of that stuff but
more of them are willing to make some
concessions about either pre-existing
conditions or whatever else so the point
is if the Democratic Party moves to the
left it will force because we know that
the public is moving left as well it
will force the Republican Party to come
somewhat to the left and then we've got
to work at the local level I know that
it's it sounds so boring it sounds
almost cliche it sounds almost axiomatic
to say Democrats have to be working at
the local level but Democrats just don't
do it well the Democrats don't do it
well that's the reality and what happens
is there's a sort of twofold effect
number one by working really well at the
local level everything from school
boards to City Council's to mayorships
of smaller towns and cities with all
that stuff what Republicans do is they
make it so that they aren't in a
position to have to make things happen
at the state or federal level as quickly
because they have all these people
already doing it when it comes to
curricula in schools because they've got
the school boards all of these other
things if we can get involved in that we
are going to have a lot of those same
successes presumably but also they have
basically like a farm team to use a
baseball analogy they've got the minor
leagues and they have all sorts of
people from which they can handpick the
most charismatic and the most sort of PR
friendly and then start winning bigger
races in the House of Representative
some of these folks can even become
senators etc so those are the two areas
where Democrats need to start working
right away if we want to move the
Republican Party to the left we know the
way to do it move ourselves to the left
as leftists both through the Democratic
Party and outside of it and we've got to
start winning the local races it's just
it's a bit it's truly disheartening to
see the degree to which Democrats have
failed at the local level for so many
years and in large swaths of the United
States